he's Brooks koepka the freshly minted
PGA Tour player of the year who joins us
now
congratulations Brooks how are you today
nice day appreciate it everything good
yeah what do you get for a PGA Tour
Player of the Year an incredible trophy
of Jack Nicklaus it's actually pretty
cool it's it's a cool trophy to have I
was telling someone earlier you know
anytime you can get anything with this
his name on it is pretty it's pretty
special do you have a do you have it now
not in front of me right now it's in
another room it's in the other room okay
but when you're done could you walk all
the way to that other room and take a
picture for us absolutely yeah that's
what we did last time running it yeah
yeah just tweet it out and you know I'd
like to be able to see it first time you
met Jack Nicklaus what did you say I
think I was in shock I was like mr.
Nicklaus and just nothing came out you
know I grew up down in West Palm so we'd
see him a little bit there was a couple
junior golf tournament so were that one
named after him and and that he would
come out too and kind of hand the
trophies out and they got won won twice
one of those golf tournaments so we got
to see him a little bit and obviously
just growing up here you might run into
him every once in a while but he's a
class act
mr. Nicklaus is basically somebody you
want to emulate he's he's an incredible
guy and he's always fun to be around
would you have voted for you for PGA
Tour Player of the Year I didn't I
actually I was too lazy I didn't vote
but yeah I don't know I would never vote
for myself I just I just couldn't do it
who would you vote for I would never
vote I would maybe the way Bryson came
on as of late if not maybe Dustin I one
of those guys who over to voted for but
yeah then this next next year I get next
year I'm gonna vote doesn't the sport
feel differently Tiger back or does it
feel different oh it's way different
it's way different it's so good to have
them back
anytime you can see it when you go to an
event you can feel the energy there's
double the amount of people that are
there double the amount of people that
I'm sure that are watching at home you
can feel the atmosphere you know where
he's at at all times I don't care if
you're on the driving range and he's on
the sixth hole you know even in his
practice rounds people are screaming and
born if he hits it close it's fun to be
playing golf with Tiger Woods it really
is it's good for the sport it's good for
us it's good to have them back and you
know it makes this next year even that
more exciting if I said one shot that
you would want us to show the video of
that would sum up your season your year
what would it be the most memorable one
for me was 16 at Belle Reve the par-3 I
think I had four and in there - about
six feet and being I think gave me a two
shot lead and going to the last two
which is which is always a little bit
nicer than one but it was it was an
incredible golf shot flighted
beautifully in my number and under that
much pressure when you've got Tiger on
your tails is never is never easy I
wanted to see you two play together
because you know we always talked about
these guys who go toe to toe with Tiger
and then they melt down your like
personality disposition it you don't get
too hired too low so I don't know if
Tiger would have had more of any impact
on you if you two played together that
day what do you think it doesn't matter
to me it doesn't matter who you play
with you know I'm there I kind of
actually funny story I learned my lesson
the first time I ever played with them
it was at the PGA Championship in 2000 I
think 13 and I must have shot 42 on the
frontside Wow but I'd done what I have
done my entire life I spent the first
nine holes were watching him and you get
caught up just watching him like he's a
kid alright so I did I watched him on TV
if one's girlfriend and I watched them
when I was there and then now all the
sudden you find yourself playing with
them and you're watching them again and
I'm like well I'm here I got a I
actually have to play golf
so the back nine I'm just gonna try to
do what I'm supposed to do and it was a
good learning lesson for me and it's you
know you see it with a bunch of the
young kids that come out they don't they
don't exactly play well with them
because they've just done that but I've
learned I've grown a little bit since
then and I mean I enjoy playing with
them he's fun to play with and obviously
you can the roars and the people that
are there it's definitely an exciting
time when you're playing with them you
golf on your days off no not really
I'd much rather be either in the gym or
on the boat or doing going fishing and
if I can I mean yeah I try to practice a
little bit before I head out to an event
but you know stays off you got to find
what works for you but you've got
buddies and I'm sure they want to play
golf or all your buddies guys who play
on tour oh no all my buddies Billy they
play a little bit of golf you know it
was funny I took my best friend out for
his bachelor party in Vegas and they all
could not wait to play golf and all I
was thinking was man I just really want
some time off I mean I went played with
them but I think I only played like nine
holes and just watch them the rest of
the time but you know Dave they love to
golf my best friends could care less but
they try to play as much golf as they
can and they know if I'm around I'll
come out and just watch and let them
play he's Brookes captain of the PGA
Tour Player of the Year joining a Stan
Patrick's show do you watch Florida
State football I wish I could say I'm
not watching it but yes I do watch it so
you watched that and that meltdown
against Miami yeah it was funny we've
got a buddy of mine it was a big Miami
fan and he was there and we were they
have this big group chat with you know
ten good buddies of mine and we were
lighting him up early and then he wasn't
because we were overseas and by the time
I woke up I'm looking at the score of
the game I'm going what just happened
well yeah I just missed the last quarter
and I was like what you got to be
kidding me but yeah he definitely it
it's not good right now
not good to say to your ford estate fan
right now you've had a few days to kind
of digest the Ryder Cup if I gave the
team a mulligan
what would the team have done
differently in the Ryder Cup you know I
don't know maybe just an extra day there
I mean obviously it's hard coming off
the Tour Championship a little bit of
jet lag that's not an excuse but maybe
it's another day to figure out the
greens a little bit it took me a while
to figure it I don't know about the rest
of the guys but just you know keeping up
the speed on the greens we didn't make
any putts
there's there's no excuse for it at the
end of day it seems gonna win and team's
gonna loose and the team that plays
better he's gonna win
and we just didn't do that and you know
you got to make putts if you want to win
I've never seen anybody not make putts
and win a golf tournament so we just
didn't do we didn't take care of
business and in simple eyes and fairway
Jesus Tommy Fleetwood had a hell of a
time he was he was it couldn't stop
celebrating man no he he looked like he
was enjoying it and as he should have
you know the Ryder Cup debut and to play
as well as he did is incredible and he's
he's an unbelievable player you know
everybody's just starting to know who he
is in the States but in Europe he's been
he's been the real deal for a while I
want to set the record straight we can
put it to bed why do you think it was
reported that you and Dustin Johnson had
that altercation at a party I have no
idea we went in there to go congratulate
the Europeans and and Tom Congrats on on
the job well done and and say hey and I
don't know how this started I have no
idea I mean I've been texting with him I
was texting with him before I even knew
the story even existed and we chatted a
few times during the week and as we
normally would and then I saw him this
morning and you know the 20 people that
were here can vouch for me that there's
there's nothing there we don't get it
we've laughed about it we talked about
it and do you think somebody
misconstrued something like they may
have seen you guys like I just don't
know why somebody would report it
created yeah I have no idea you know we
could
I mean we talked about everything and we
could have been talking about college
football and how bad Florida State was
and I was probably you know what I mean
it could have been one of those things
I'm like dude we're not that bad and
then you never know what somebody heard
or what they said you know sometimes you
jump in the middle of a conversation you
have no idea what's going on you just
hear a certain part of it but it's not
it's not always the case and I don't
know what what they think they saw or
what they think they heard but it was it
was far from the truth do you think he
could have taken him I don't know it
would be a good match I mean I've seen
I'd say I've seen I've seen instances
I'm sure I'm sure it'd be a good fight
it'd be maybe not as good as that
McGregor fight and commute by but
whether or the fight after the fight but
it would definitely would be interesting
maybe sell a few few tickets yeah and I
think PGA Tour kid could do that like a
just a who oh I could you know what I
could do here I got Patrick Reed and I
got jordan Spieth in the Octagon what do
you think if we're really gonna sell
this though Brooks I could get maybe
Tiger Phil okay but who's the main match
oh you against Dustin okay all right
yeah oh yeah absolutely yeah cuz I can
sell that because there's drama
although Patrick Reed against Jordan
would be really interesting I think we
could sell that one too it'd be
interesting all right go take a picture
of your trophy and tweet it out and
congratulations and thanks for being a
good sport yeah you got it thanks I hear
that's Brooks koepka PGA Tour PGA Tour
Player of the Year for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
at
you